hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Samantha
Ashley Bell we're gonna watch the
trailer for a George Lucas animated
flick strange magic
I hope it's about I it's gonna be good
let's watch it magic I don't use it and
you you're gonna go there see them
anyway it's a kids movie enjoy no no I'm
sorry guys you can't take him anywhere
[Music]
I
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I enjoy the trailer it seems funny but
there's something about it especially
because it's a January movie that makes
me go okay first off people are going
it's George Lucas but at the same time
this doesn't look like anything that
unique and special to me it could be
kind of funny
but it seems a little bit over the top
it seems like it's trying to be like
other companies that have succeeded at
this already like there's almost like a
Shrek feel to some of it and like some
of the jokes yeah it was their movie
that came out already with a similar
plot just like last year I think so
probably I don't know I mean it looked
very similar I didn't see any catch it
but as far as the animation goes though
I think that the characters in like the
entire world but it looks Oh looks cool
especially the they're not called
midgets what are they called trolls no
the little dudes with the faces and
stuff you know faces the little people
with the pointy hats what are they no no
no yeah they look real okay this is very
specific but I think it's cool that the
characters like you can see their eyes
so clearly I don't know that's something
that I don't see done a lot in animation
that they're very human looking very
realistic I'm a little confused on what
this story exactly is it wasn't very
clear it was like a lot was going on
this is a long trailer I still I'm not
sure what this is about I don't know if
I'll end up seeing this one I did laugh
at their jokes but I think there's a
little much with some of the songs
it doesn't look appealing for itself
okay I'm sorry to do this but I'm going
to compare it to Pixar Pixar tends to
make movies that like the whole family
will want to check this out this looks
like it's just for little kids they're
trying to make it for the parents
because that's why they're having like
so not working it's so not worth you
know I don't they did they tried too
hard that's the problem it's like
they're trying to yeah they're not doing
they're just trying doors Lucas should
have listened to Yoda see how I did that
he said
do or do not there is no try the force
seconds is all night I always get my
Yoda golem and stitch confused hello I'm
touch and then golems like stupid pat
robertson's that's creepy they all kind
of sound similar there should be a show
about golem stitch and Yoda moving to
the Big Apple to make it in Hollywood
moving on How I Met Your Mother
far far away that's what they should
call it get it yeah anyway guys if
you're new to the channel and sorry if
you like that trailer we didn't looking
forward to those dislikes if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects do you like movies
sometimes we sometimes do you know
people are like you always like you but
you know what sometimes we happened to
come across one that we weren't a big
fan of and you can subscribe to
Samantha's channel so check out her
channel she's got two whole videos up
right now more on the way
Arnold fit hey Ryan
I love the channel you and all the
rejects make my day every time I watch
your guys's video keep up the great work
no shout-out needed well Arnold oh my
god he said no shout-out you know that
means he's so humble he deserves a
shout-out he deserves a badass shout out
for someone to go on the Rio reject
shout out page my hair looks so weird
for someone to go on the real reject
shout-out page and then say no shout-out
needed he just loves the real rejects
not much that he's seen his name of
Arnold bit though you deserve it
dude you are cool yeah do the chopper
and today's a day of awesome impressions
that's what I'm doing they're so awesome
they're real awesome REE l but they're
also rejected awesome they're not really
good good yeah because I'm rejecting
them I know I used the girls rejecting
me at every chance they get Veronica
doesn't only after 10 [ __ ] years at
persistence or is down resistance for us
org
or orgy hey Ryan you are literally one
of the definitions of Awesome's you're
not afraid of what you want to say and
you make a trailer reaction youtube
channel look really cool because I
thought people will get bored of it but
no you know how to make an awesome one
huh I would feel flattered but I just
know all this hey now what happened it'd
be no one you know you also know how to
make your fans left and can i have a
shout out thanks man
ok for Ross or D Heaney 3 R's is it's a
type of sex position did you know that
that is where it's a brand new one that
is where you watch a sci-fi movie while
getting head and then at the climax of
the movie is when you climax along with
it so are your in unison with the climax
of the film and then yes [ __ ] on the
girl's face no you don't do that please
don't don't listen to his advice trust
needs I haven't personally tried to get
a good boy I hear it's awesome where do
you read about these so-called new
positions Bri do you think I read it's
called pornhub.com thanks for watching
this kids hope you enjoyed the video